[Music]
well you you even said that you were
your lifelong Red Sox fan that you were
disappointed that you're a little
disappointed that the the Red Sox but
you're not unhappy that they're losing
now no I mean what are burn off all the
bandwagon okay all those people with the
pink Red Sox hats
singing that stupid song in the seventh
inning Caroline yeah pop um your girl's
got her head on your shoulder like
you're at a romantic comedy it's just
not what they got like a mascot now they
got a massive got a mask I know they had
a mask that's right a mascot in the late
70s and the guy got pelted with so many
like cigarette lighters he quit after
like three games and that's what I mean
now I come back to boss and everybody's
like they they like holding I ain't no
swaying singing this song it's just it's
the Patriots have like a lighthouse at
their stadium now I just it's just not
the city I left so you're bitter that
they had that success are you happy that
they won died I like that they want I'd
like them to continue winning but I
don't think we have to sing campfire
songs and like the seventh-inning okay I
don't like mascots I don't like those
songs and Steve Jobs I think was a
little overrated
[Applause]
you love it you love it you love going
against the grain it's fantastic I like
annoying people okay on that subject
then Debu to watch the conventions
Republican convention a Democratic
convention no I think if you watch those
you're an idiot
why you would sit there wasting your
time they all say the same thing they're
all like you know over the last four
years everything good that happened was
cuz of us and we would have done more
good stuff if it wasn't for those guys
and then they the Democrats go we did
all the good stuff I think you're all
working for the same guy they've been on
both horses and then it just kind of
goes you know it's not for you all right
you vote for that guy that says like
there's a meteor headed right towards
the planet that's the guy you vote for
so it's a psycho cuz there's no way
there's any corporate money behind that
guy
on TV he's gonna come on TV like reading
files from the Pentagon like you know
what else they're doing and as
unsettling as that is at least you can
you can believe in it you can trust it
you know that that no corporations
behind him they're not getting any money
on the side cuz I think both the
Democrats Republican they just say the
same thing they just say those applause
break I think it's time to get this
country back to work and every some guy
was like a Tennessee sign jumping up and
down like these part of it we're all
we're all gonna get replaced by like
robots that's where I think like
eventually you think we're all gonna be
replaced by robots
yeah according to my YouTube and
Wikipedia research I think that's see a
bunch you know what I don't I don't have
any kids and if you go too long you just
it you just you get a little crazy you
know you become a become like that black
dude and not predator remember that guy
like I see it over there in them trees
[Applause]
chili
shaving your head yeah you gotta have
something I gotta have a kid that's what
I got to do I should just have a kid and
play catch with them you know why don't
tell them that you know Santa's coming
and all that right no I think it's too
big
I am saying when I'm feeling please give
me that that's good you are saying what
you're feeling I want to make sure I
mentioned this new special you people
are all the same we'll be available
online October 1st at billboard.com
right and I'm hoping people are gonna
actually download it and pay for it I am
hoping that's a big risk now yeah
that could become like $140,000 business
card if you're gonna steal it can you
just be honest and just say I stole it
can you just do that don't be like we're
not stealing it we're sharing it hate to
tell you this Lars was right he was
right it's stealing okay I guess so
you know Lars from Metallica yeah okay
monster movie Lars turn the switch
[Laughter]